this is a Fox News Alert the lawyer for
the adult film actress who says she had
a relationship sexual relationship with
then businessman Donald Trump has been
arrested on a domestic violence charge
that is according to The Associated
Press in just the past few minutes
Michael avenatti was arrested today
after his estranged wife filed a felony
domestic violence report the TMZ is
reporting that her face was swollen and
bruised the AP citing a law enforcement
official with the LAPD saying that
avenatti is in police custody at this
hour following domestic violence
allegation we'll continue to follow that
story